There are whole books written about this algorithm. Though at its simplest, it
can fit on the back of a business card, such as this old one of Paul
Heckbert's. There are even ray tracers with amazing animated effects that are
written in 256 bytes, such as this demo scene program called Tube. Well,
actually, this program is only 252 bytes. The last four bytes spell out the
author's name, Baze. This is one of the most amazing programs I've ever seen.
This is as far as I'm going to go with ray tracing, but you now have a taste of
its power. Shadows, sharp reflections and refraction can all be added easily.
There's been much work to make ray tracers generate images at interactive rates
for complex scenes. We're not quite there yet for some applications, and there
are headaches with keeping a constant frame rate in reasonable quality. But
we'll clearly see more progress in this area in the future.